if you were provided this question just
on the face of it here's question you
know eight part a in an exam and you
just saw that that's all you saw okay
what would be your first instinct what
kinds of things can we do not are they
good ideas let's just think what can we
do physically yeah sure yeah okay so I
come back to the first point you said
have you got all these factors right ah
you've got swallow the factory here but
they don't seem to match up it anyway
right so therefore it's not a terrible
idea to expand everything out and then
crush your figures that whoever wrote
this paper makes it all cancel out and I
said neatly okay I'll just fast forward
and time travel for you and tell you it
doesn't happen nothing works out nicely
on the left-hand side count the number
of factors what kind of polynomial do
you expect to get out the other it it's
a kwatak power form right now you've got
an x squared term here and an X term and
a constant term but they don't really
accomplish anything nice and the over on
the left hand side you still end up with
a messy quartic so then we rewind and we
say is there anything else I can do
do we have any ideas apart from just
expanding just give us a shot just throw
us up it'll see if it sticks on the wall
okay so another version of this strategy
is to say look this thing here looks a
little more workable that this thing
here like I know this is going to become
this unmitigated disaster if I expand
this is somewhat tidy like I maybe could
do something with it
factorize it in an other way 5x squared
+ 25 X plus 18 I'm gonna give you a
suggestion
remember um I think yesterday one of the
quadratics I gave you is I don't know
something something like this right and
we looked at it and we immediately saw
without any computation
don't bother factorizing this and the
big flashing clue was the 7 right now
this is not the only clue that should
tell you factorizing is a bad idea
if we just because it will just take us
one second if we just expand this watch
what happens
5x squared + 25 X plus 18 all right now
5 times 18 is 90 90 90
25 hmm doesn't take you very far does it
and here's the reason I know I need to
have something that's gonna multiply to
90 right but you can see the factors
here are gonna have to somehow fit into
this but none of them do it's it's not
going to give you anything so even if
you went down this alley it doesn't get
you very much progress ok so again I'm
gonna rewind and I'm going to give you
that clue I said at the beginning which
is that this comes in an exercise about
equations that are reducible to
quadratics ok now this does sort of
stick out doesn't it what's that doing
there okay this at least seems like
someone made that up but why is this
separated out that's why I didn't seem
like a bad idea expanded ok this thing
here is the key
this guy is hiding over on the left hand
side actually it's hiding there twice we
just need to be able to find it now you
can see if we did expand this if we did
expand this it's maybe the whole thing
would give us a quartic okay but you
could expand them partially you could
extend say pears for instance
if you expanded these to just these to
forget about the rest of them okay what
would you get you get x squared plus
plus 3x plus 2 what did you cuz look
there's the pair of numbers they add to
3 there multiply to 2 so that's what you
would get x squared plus 3x plus 2
that's easy to deal with but it doesn't
have anything to do with this right and
of course that's because this is not the
only pairing up that I can do over here
on the left hand side there are other
things that I can pair for instance
instead of pairing off the X plus 2 with
this guy let's check hang up the X plus
2 that's a bad choice of color let's
pair up the X plus 2 with this guy what
will I get you should recognize this
this is my favorite quadratic function
of all time okay you're like oh wait
this thing this thing is not the same
but it's clearly related to this isn't
it and at the same way if you have a
look at what's left if I use these two
up expanded those then what I'm left
with is these these ones one of a
expensive x squared plus 5x plus 4
either gears turning yet do you see what
we've done here with a clever choice of
what's over here on the left because you
can choose this is the most important
part the most important part of last
problem is the choosy about the actual
computing okay if we choose these well
on the left hand side I'm gonna get this
what was the first one you gave me plus
6 that guy from the middle 2 and then
this from the ends does that make sense
so this is the same as the first line
and what I have over here doesn't need
to change ok so now can you tell me your
substitution
what should i let's introduce the
substitution like you what should you be
equal to yeah there is 1 2 3 he appears
all of those times so if I let u equal
what you just told me I tell me that's
right on the next
you + 6 u + 4 equals what have we done
to our kwatak we have reduced it to a
quadratic and I reckon you guys can take
over from there okay in fact can you see
what you get
you're going to get a solution for you
and then you're going to go the next
step because you want to go back to X's
ok any questions 8 Jake d4c 84 so okay
which is--what's-- one of the things
that society so what did I see this
question that maybe you struggled to see
at the beginning actually not that much
I tried the same things you guys did but
I quickly realized they weren't giving
me anything useful so then I had to
pedal back and think well is there
another strategy that I can use are they
weird weird things in it that maybe I
can take advantage of make sense